هي لغه كل الايام بالنسبه لابنائها الوطن
الكبير
يستعملونها كل يوم يعلمها الكبار للصغار
وتحدث بها اكثر من 300 مليون شخص في هذا
العالم انها اللغه العربيه التي احتفلت
يوم امس 18 من ديسمبر ليومها العالمي
ويحتفل العرب بها لمده اسبوع كامل فيما
يعرف باسبوع اللغه العربيه في المانيا
التي تشهد احدث موجه هجره عربيه يظل تعليم
اللغه العربيه من بين الامور التي تشغل
بال المهاجرين العرب فالمهاجر يريد
لابنائه تعلم لغتها من الام وربطها
وجدانيا بالوطن حيث العائلات العربيه خاصه
الواصلون الجدد في السنوات الاخيره الذين
يحرصون على ابقاء اللغات العربيه حيه في
ابها ثاني اولادهم من خلال ارسالهم الى
مدرسه تعلم اللغه العربيه في عطله نهايه
الاسبوع
يقرع جرس المدرسه هنا رغم انه يوم السبت
يهرب الطلاب الى صفوفهم في اليوم الاول من
عطله الاسبوع في برلين الصفوف هنا ليست
اجباريه فالمدرسه هي مدرسه لتعليم اللغه
العربيه
الى
مملكه العربيه السعوديه
الى المانيا ياتون الى هنا مره في الاسبوع
لتعلم القراءه والكتابه
العربيه لازم اعرف احكي واكتب بالعربي
لغه الدين عندي لانه عربي ولازم اعرف
اقرا قران منيح عشان هيك لازم اعرف اقرا
عربي لغه القران
التي تعلم العربيه هنا ايضا يقولون بانهم
يريدون لاولادهم ان يحافظوا على لغتهم ولا
ينسونها الاء الموجوده في دمشق وصلت الى
المانيا قبل خمس سنوات وتعلم ابنتيها
العربيه في هذه المدرسه
مسلسلاتنا برامجنا كلها باللغه العربيه
تقريبا
فما بلاقي صعوبه هنا هم كثير حابين هذا
الشعر كثير همم يمكن لانه انا عم بزرع
فيهم محبه اللغه العربيه
ومن خلال التواصل الدائمه اقرباء بالعكس
بتستمتعه يعني وثلاثه ارباع وقتهن بعدين
بالمدارس الالمانيه بتخاف مثل اي ام
بيخافوا ان اولادها ينسوا اللغه العربيه
ما عاد عندهم هالرقبه فشجعوا من خلال
القصص والروايات مدرسه
اكثر من 600 طالبن يدرسون في ثلاثه حصص
مختلفه يوم السبت الاحد
90% من الطلبه العرب من القادم هل يتم
يرغبون التدريس ابنائهم اللغه العربيه
للمحافظه على ثقافتهم وجذورهم وايضا همم
للسهوله التواصل مع اولياء امورهم في
اقربائهم
هو يغادر الطلاب ومعهم بضعه كلمات اضافيه
كل اسبوع يامل وذويهم ان تبقى معهم حتى
يكبروا لتذكرهم بجذورهم وثقافتهم رغبهم
العربيه بنين
واللغه العربيه وجمالها في تفردها
ومفرداتها نحن سنجرب معكم قراءه هذه
الابيات العجيبه من اللغه العربيه نبدا
معكم في البيت الاول
وقبر حربا بمكان قصر وليس قرب قبر حرب قبر
القبر هنا يعني المكان الخالي الذي لا شيء
حوله وتدللت البيت ان القبر لا شيء حوله
فهو في مكان بعيد لوحده
الم الم الم بدائه ان ان ان ان اوانه هذا
من اصعب ابيات المتنبي شرحه يطول جدا
ويتحدث عن الالم بطريقه عجيبه ليس معها
اشواق
كان كان صعب وقدرتي تنجحي في المهمه وهذا
التحدي فتى فوتنا في فتاه فتاه وبات بسبب
الفتاه فتاه اظن هذا البيت اشهر من
البيتين السابقين لكن مترادفه فيه كثيره
وهنا كان الاعجاز والابداع الادبي صادق
صديقا صادقا في صدقه فصدق الصداقه في صديق
صادق كذلك هذا البيت هو الشاعر بسيط لكنه
كثير المترادفات نجحنا في التحدي نجحنا
ونصف بس احنا كمان بدنا نوكل التحدي للناس
الوطن العربي الوطن العربي ونشوف مين نجح
في تحدي اللغه العربيه في محاولات مصر
العراق والاردن قراءه بعضنا الجمل العربيه
الساحره من الشعر العربي متابع ونرى من
الفائز بالتحدي العربي
[موسيقى]
صادق صديقا صادقا في صدقه
الصداقه في صديق صادق
في فتاه
وبات بسبب الفتاه
[موسيقى]
ههه فتن في فتاين فتيات وبات بسبب الفتاه
فتى صادق صديق صادق في صدقه فصدقه الصداقه
في صديق صادق
[موسيقى]
ده ده عربي جديد ده عربي اول مره اشوفه
ايوه قبل حرب بمكان قفر وليس قرب قبر حربه
قبر ان ان ان ان هو انا
فتى فتى في فتاه
وبات بسبب الفتاه وبات بسبب الفتاه صادق
صديقا
[موسيقى]
وقبر الحرب في مكان قبري وليس قربه قبر
حرب
الفتاه
صادق صديقا صادقا في صدقه فصدق الصداقه في
صديق صادقا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وليس قرب قبر حرب قبر الم الم الم بدائه
ان ان ان انو اوانه فتى فتنا في فتاه فتاه
وبات بسبب الفتاه
صادق صديقا صادقا في صدقه فصدق الصداقه في
صديق صادقا
[موسيقى]
فتاه فتاه
بسبب فتاه قبل حرب في مكان قصر وليس قرب
قبر فتاه في فتاه فتاه وبات بسبب الفتاه
الفتاه
قفري وليس بقبر قبر فتاه في فتاه فتاه
صادقا
في صدقه
فصدق في الصداقه في صديق صادقا
[موسيقى]
وسهام انا كتبت في تغريده يوم امس ان
اللغه العربيه قوه ومصداقيه لمن يظهر على
الشاشه فنحن نحترم من يتقنها ونعتذر
لمشاهدين الكرام ان اخطانا يوما ما عن قصد
او عن غير قصد في هذه اللغه فعلينا ان
نحترمها ونحبها ونحافظ عليها حضاري من
الفكر والتراث